La química es la heroína de las comunicaciones electrónicas.
Y mi objetivo hoy es convencerlos
para que estén de acuerdo conmigo
Bien, comencemos simple;
echen un vistazo dentro de estos dispositivos increíblemente adictivos.
Porque sin química,
lo qué es una autopista de la información que amamos
sería un pisapapeles brillante y muy caro.
La química permite todas estas capas.
Comencemos en la pantalla.
¿Cómo creen que obtenemos esos colores vivos y brillantes
que amamos tanto?
Bueno, se los diré.
Hay polímeros orgánicos incrustados dentro de la pantalla,
que puede tomar electricidad y convertirla en el azul, rojo y verde
que disfrutamos en nuestras fotos.
¿Qué pasa si nos movemos hacia la batería?
Actualmente hay una intensa investigación.
¿Cómo tomamos los principios químicos de las baterías tradicionales
y los emparejamos con electrodos nuevos de alta superficie,
para que podamos almacenar más carga en un espacio más pequeño,
para poder alimentar nuestros dispositivos todo el día,
mientras nos hacemos selfis
sin tener que recargar nuestras baterías
o sentarnos atados a un enchufe?
¿Y qué si vamos a los adhesivos que lo unen todo
para que puedan soportar nuestro uso frecuente?
Después de todo, como un milenia,
tengo que sacar mi teléfono al menos 200 veces al día para revisarlo,
y en el proceso, lo suelto dos o tres veces.
Pero ¿cuáles son los cerebros de estos dispositivos?
¿Qué los hace trabajar de la forma en que lo amamos tanto?
Bueno, eso tiene que ver con componentes eléctricos y circuitos.
que están atados a una placa de circuito impreso.
O tal vez prefieren una metáfora biológica:
la placa base, es posible que hayan oído hablar de eso.
Ahora, de la placa de circuito impreso realmente no se habla mucho.
Y voy a ser sincera, no sé por qué es eso.
Quizás es porque es la capa menos sexy
y está oculta debajo de todas esas otras capas de aspecto elegante.
Pero es hora de finalmente dar esta capa de Clark Kent
el elogio digno de Superman que merece.
Y entonces les hago una pregunta.
¿qué creen que es una placa de circuito impreso?
Bueno, piensen en una metáfora.
Piensen en la ciudad en la que viven.
Tiene todos esos puntos de interés a los que desean llegar:
su casa, su trabajo, restaurantes,
un par de Starbucks en cada cuadra.
Entonces construimos caminos que los conectan a todos.
Eso es lo que es una placa de circuito impreso.
Excepto que, en lugar de tener cosas como restaurantes,
tenemos transistores en chips,
condensadores, resistencias,
todos estos componentes eléctricos
que necesitan encontrar una manera de hablar entre ellos.
¿Y cuáles son nuestros caminos?
Bueno, construimos pequeños cables de cobre.
La siguiente pregunta es:
¿Cómo hacemos estos pequeños cables de cobre?
Son realmente pequeños.
¿Podría ser que fuéramos a la ferretería,
tomáramos un carrete de alambre de cobre,
unos cortadores de alambre, un pequeño clip,
ver todo y luego, bam, ¿tenemos nuestra placa de circuito impresa?
De ninguna manera.
Estos cables son demasiado pequeños para eso.
Entonces tenemos que confiar en nuestra amiga: la química.
El proceso químico para hacer estos pequeños cables de cobre
es aparentemente simple.
Comenzamos con una solución.
de esferas de cobre con carga positiva.
Luego le agregamos una placa de circuito impreso aislante.
Y alimentamos esas esferas cargadas positivamente
con electrones cargados negativamente
agregando formaldehído a la mezcla.
Quizás recuerden el formaldehído.
Olor muy distintivo
utilizado para preservar ranas en la clase de biología.
Bueno, resulta que puede hacer mucho más que eso.
Es un componente realmente clave
para hacer estos pequeños cables de cobre.
Los electrones en formaldehído tienen una unidad.
Quieren saltar a esas esferas de cobre cargadas positivamente.
Y todo eso se debe a un proceso conocido como química redox.
Y cuando eso pasa,
podemos tomar estas esferas de cobre cargadas positivamente
y convertirlas en brillantes
pulidos metales conductores.
Y una vez que tenemos cobre conductor,
ahora estamos cocinando con gas.
Y podemos tenemos todos los componentes eléctricos
para hablar unos con otros.
Así que gracias una vez más a la química.
Y pensemos
y piensen en lo lejos que hemos llegado con la química.
Claramente, en comunicaciones electrónicas,
el tamaño importa.
Así que pensemos en cómo podemos reducir nuestros dispositivos,
para que podamos pasar de nuestro teléfono celular Zack Morris de los 90
a algo un poco más elegante,
como los teléfonos de hoy que caben en nuestros bolsillos.
Aunque, seamos realistas aquí:
absolutamente nada cabe en los bolsillos de los pantalones de mujer,
si puedes encontrar un par de pantalones con bolsillos.
(Risas)
Y no creo que la química nos pueda ayudar con ese problema.
Pero más importante que reducir el dispositivo real,
¿cómo encogemos los circuitos dentro de él
y reducirlos 100 veces,
para que podamos tomar los circuitos de la escala de micras
todo el camino hasta la escala nanométrica?
Porque, seamos sinceros,
en este momento, todos queremos teléfonos más potentes y rápidos.
Bueno, más potencia y más rapidez requieren más circuitos.
Entonces, ¿cómo hacemos esto?
No es que tengamos un rayo mágico electromagnético retráctil,
como el que el profesor Wayne Szalinski usó en "Cariño, encogí a los niños"
para encoger a sus hijos.
Por accidente, por supuesto.
¿Lo haríamos?
Bueno, en realidad, en el campo,
hay un proceso que es bastante similar a eso.
Y su nombre es fotolitografía.
En fotolitografía, tomamos radiación electromagnética,
o lo que tendemos a llamar luz,
y la usamos para reducir algunos de esos circuitos,
para que podamos meter más en un espacio realmente pequeño.
Ahora, ¿cómo funciona esto?
Bueno, comenzamos con un sustrato
que tiene una película sensible a la luz.
Luego lo cubrimos con una máscara que tiene un patrón encima
de líneas finas y características
que harán que el teléfono funcione de la manera que queremos.
Luego exponemos una luz brillante y la hacemos brillar a través de esta máscara,
que crea una sombra de ese patrón en la superficie.
Ahora, en cualquier lugar donde la luz pueda atravesar la máscara,
va a causar una reacción química.
Y eso va a quemar la imagen de ese patrón en el sustrato.
La pregunta que es probable que se estén haciendo es:
¿cómo pasamos de una imagen quemada
a limpiar líneas finas y características?
Y para eso, tenemos que usar una solución química
llamada el desarrollador.
Ahora el desarrollador es especial.
Lo que puede hacer es tomar todas las áreas no expuestas
y eliminarlas selectivamente,
dejando líneas y rasgos finos y limpios,
y hacer que nuestros dispositivos miniaturizados funcionen.
Hemos usado química ahora para construir nuestros dispositivos,
y la hemos usado para reducir nuestros dispositivos.
Quizá los he convencido de que la química es la verdadera heroína,
y podríamos deajrlo allí.
(Aplausos)
Esperen, no hemos terminado.
No tan rapido.
Porque todos somos humanos.
Y como humana, siempre quiero más.
Y ahora quiero pensar en cómo usar la química
para extraer más de un dispositivo.
En este momento, nos dicen que queremos algo llamado 5G,
o la prometida quinta generación de tecnología inalámbrica.
Ahora, es posible que hayan oído hablar de 5G
en comerciales que comienzan a aparecer.
O tal vez algunos de Uds. lo experimentaron
en los Juegos Olímpicos de invierno 2018.
Lo que más me entusiasma de 5G
es que, cuando voy tarde, salgo corriendo de la casa para tomar un avión,
puedo descargar películas en mi dispositivo en 40 segundos
en lugar de 40 minutos.
Pero cuando el verdadero 5G esté aquí,
van a ser mucho más que cuántas películas
podemos poner en nuestro dispositivo.
La pregunta es, ¿por qué el verdadero 5G no está aquí?
Y les contaré un pequeño secreto.
Es bastante fácil de responder.
Es simplemente difícil de hacer.
Ya ven, si usan esos materiales tradicionales y cobre
para construir dispositivos 5G,
la señal no puede llegar a su destino final.
Tradicionalmente, utilizamos capas aislantes muy rugosas
para apoyar los alambres de cobre.
Piensen en los cierres de velcro.
Es la aspereza de las dos piezas lo que las une.
Eso es muy importante si quieren tener un dispositivo
que va a durar más
de lo que lleva sacarlo de la caja
y comenzar a instalar todas sus aplicaciones en él.
Pero esta aspereza causa un problema.
Ya ves, a altas velocidades para 5G
la señal tiene que viajar cerca de esa aspereza.
Y hace que se pierda antes de llegar a su destino final.
Piensen en una cadena montañosa.
Y tienen un complejo sistema de caminos que lo recorren,
e intentan llegar al otro lado.
¿No están de acuerdo conmigo
que probablemente llevaría mucho tiempo,
y probablemente uno se perdería,
si tuviera que subir y bajar todas las montañas,
a diferencia de si uno acaba de perforar un túnel plano
que podría pasar directamente?
Bueno, es lo mismo en nuestros dispositivos 5G.
Si pudiéramos eliminar esta aspereza,
entonces podríamos enviar la señal 5G
directamente sin interrupciones.
Suena bastante bien, ¿verdad?
Pero esperen.
¿no les acabo de decir que necesitábamos esa aspereza
para mantener el dispositivo unido?
Y si la quitamos, estamos en una situación donde ahora el cobre
no se va a quedar con ese sustrato subyacente.
Piensen en construir una casa de bloques de Lego,
con todos los rincones y grietas que se unen,
a diferencia de los bloques de construcción lisos.
¿Cuál de los dos tendrá más integridad estructural
cuando el niño de dos años llega terrorífico a la sala de estar,
tratando de jugar Godzilla y derribar todo?
¿Pero qué pasa si ponemos pegamento en esos bloques lisos?
Y eso es lo que la industria está esperando.
Están esperando que los químicos diseñen nuevas superficies lisas
con mayor adhesión inherente
para algunos de esos alambres de cobre.
Y cuando resolvamos este problema,
y resolveremos el problema
y trabajaremos con físicos e ingenieros
para resolver todos los desafíos de 5G,
bueno, entonces el número de aplicaciones se disparará.
Así que sí, tendremos cosas como autos sin conductor,
porque entonces nuestras redes de datos pueden manejar las velocidades
y la cantidad de información requerida para que funcione.
Pero empecemos a usar la imaginación.
Me imagino yendo a un restaurante con un amigo que tiene alergia al maní,
sacando mi teléfono
agitándolo sobre la comida
y que la comida nos diga
una respuesta realmente importante a una pregunta
¿moratl o seguro de consumir?
O tal vez nuestros dispositivos se volverán tan buenos
al procesar información sobre nosotros,
que se convertirán en nuestros entrenadores personales.
Y sabrán la forma más eficiente para quemar calorías.
Sé que viene noviembre
cuando intento quemar algunas de estas libras del embarazo,
Me encantaría un dispositivo que me dijera cómo hacerlo.
Realmente no conozco otra forma de decirlo,
excepto que la química es simplemente genial.
Y habilita todos estos dispositivos electrónicos.
Entonces, la próxima vez que envíen un mensaje de texto o se tomen una selfi
piensen en todos esos átomos que están trabajando duro
y la innovación que les precedió.
Quién sabe,
tal vez incluso algunos de Uds. que escuchan esta charla,
tal vez incluso su dispositivo móvil,
decidirá que Ud. también quiere jugar al compinche
al Capitán Química,
el verdadero héroe de los dispositivos electrónicos.
Gracias por su atención,
y gracias quimica.
(Aplausos)